Mình làm phim mà mình đặc qua hả hả nè
Mình thấy thích cái cuộc chơi, cái cuộc chơi
Là cái lúc mình làm phim
Chứ mà là cái cuộc chơi lúc
Mình phải làm sống hết rồi
Mình chứ ra và trứng ra
Tộc nởi có cái cật của anh như thế nào
Vì cái cật của anh ở đây đó là em
Và như mình có vui cái vui đã cũng quan ngang mối
Mình có vô ngá về nỗi vô ngá là cũng quan ngang mối
Mình thấy thật các là mình phải được sống trong cái vui cái hành trình mình được chơi
Nhưng nó được nỗi mình được viết
Mình xửa tình câu tình chữ
Mình có được xây dựng rồi
Mày áo mình được lên, mình đặc đem
Vui là cái bản giết, anh già ra xứng là lúc mà
Là sao mà đá chứ cái băm hình đó không có giát vậy
Chỉ là chỉ nằm với chấu mà đá đi tầm
Tình góc một cực thật thay xứng rồi ra
Thế thì làm phía mà cũng như thế
Lúc mà làm phía mà làm rõ lãnh là rãnh hát xứng
Thì mà làm rõ dại
Mày nhạch rồi, mình cảm chữ của là nаем
Được chữ ở Được, giải thưởng được chị à
Vui vô của chúc xíu
Mình được khảm phúc là bởi vì được
Dơi
Gả đời
Mà cái chọn tây mình cho
Giao là mừng cái bìm này mặc
Bởi mình luôn trong trống cái vời